CIVIL LIBERTIES IF IT MEANS
INFLICTING PAIN ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
JOINING ME TO BREAK THIS DOWN,
RUDY GIULIANI PERSONAL ATTORNEY
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF THE LEFT CAN'T AGREE NOW THAT
INVESTIGATING THE ORIGINS OF
THIS PROBE THAT WAS SO EXTENSIVE
AND COST SO MUCH MONEY AND
OCCUPIED SO MUCH TIME AND
MANHOURS FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS,
WHAT IS THE POINT OF ARGUING
THESE POINTS WITH THEM AT ALL?
>> WELL, I HAVE COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION RELUCTANTLY, LAURA.
I WOULD SAY A YEAR AGO WHEN I
GOT INVOLVED REPRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT, I STILL HAD SOMETHING
LEFT OF THE IDEA IF IT'S REALLY
SERIOUS, EVEN THE LEFT WINGPRESS
WILL TAKE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS OF
CRIMES SERIOUSLY.
NOW I AM CONVINCED THEY WON'T
LISTEN TO ALLEGATIONS OF CRIMES
BY DEMOCRATS.
WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT WHEN
WE SAW HOW THEY REACTED TO
HILLARY CLINTON DESTROYING
30,000 EMAILS AND DESTROYING THE
SERVERS AND PHONES AND DEALING
WITH CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IN
A CAVALIER AND CRIMINAL MANNER.
THEY BRUSHED THAT OFF.
THEY ARE DOING THE SAME THING
WITH THIS.
THESE ARE VERY, VERY SERIOUS
CRIMES IF THEY ARE TRUE.
IF THERE IS A FALSIFIED FISA
AFFIDAVIT -- THAT'S A CERTAIN,
WAS IT KNOWING OR NEGLIGENT?
LIKE WITH HILLARY CLINTON?
THEN WE HAVE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES.
IF COMEY WAS KNOWINGLY SIGNING
THAT VERIFIED AFFIDAVIT KNOWING
THAT STEELE WAS NOT RELIABLE,
KNOWING THERE WERE THINGS WE
COULD HAVE VERIFIED THAT HE
DIDN'T, HE IS GUILTY OF MAKING
A FALSE STATEMENT UNDER OATH.
>> Laura: AND KNOWING WHO PAID
FOR THE DOSSIER.
THE FACT THAT THE OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE TO THE PRESIDENT PAID
FOR IT.
AT LEAST CALLS THE MOTIVATIONS
INTO QUESTION IF NOT THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE UNDERLYING
SALACIOUS ALLEGATIONS.
THE FACT THAT WAS NOT MADE CLEAR
IN THE FISA WARRANT, IT WOULD
HAVE TAKEN ONE SENTENCE TO DO.
THAT SPEAKS VOLUMES OF WHAT IS
INTENDED.
>> HE HAS TO KNOW HE PUT
A CORRUPT AGENT IN CHARGE OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
PETER STRZOK DEMONSTRATED IN HIS
TEXTS AND A BUNCH WERE DELETED.
MONTHS OF STRZOK AND PAGE TEXTS
WERE DELETED BY THE MUELLER
ORGANIZATION.
ASTOUNDING ACTUALLY!
AND THE PRESS DIDN'T MENTION
THAT ERECT.
EVEN WITH THE ONES WE HAVE,
PETER STRZOK HAD A PLAN TO STOP
DONALD TRUMP FROM BEING
PRESIDENT.
THE PLAN WAS THE FISA AND
SETTING UP POMADES.
COMEY EITHER TURNED INTO AN
IDIOT OR KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
PAPADOPOULOS.
THEY ENDED UP DOING A 302 RATHER
THAN INTERVIEWING HILLARY
CLINTON AND THEY WROTE THE
REPORT BEFORE THEY CONCLUDED THE
JUSTIFICATION.
-- INVESTIGATION.
AND COMEY DID A PERFORMANCE THAT
DAY THE MOST DISGRACEFUL
PERFORMANCE.
>> Laura: I JUST REWATCHED IT.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU.
THIS IS A PERFECT SEGUE.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS PART OF BARR'S INTERVIEW AS
WELL.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THE TERM
TREASON THAT THE PRESIDENT AND
OTHERS USED TO DESCRIBE SOME OF
THE BAD ACT ORS IN THE FBI.
WATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT TWEET ASKED
SAID PUBLICLY THAT SOME OF
THOSE -- COMEY AND McCABE --
COMMITTED TREASON.
>> AS A LAWYER I INTERPRET THE
WORD TREASON LEGALLY.
THERE IS A SPECIFIC CRITERIA.
I DON'T THINK IT'S IMPLICATED IN
THIS SITUATION NOW.
>> Laura: DO YOU AGREE?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
TREASON.
AS SERIOUS OR MORE SERIOUS THAN
WHAT THEY WERE TRYING TO PURSUE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON WITH NO
EVIDENCE EXCEPT THAT
PAPADOPOULOS STATEMENT.
TRYING TO REMOVE A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES ON A FALSE
CHARGE AND THEN GOING THROUGH
FALSE AFFIDAVITS, PHONEY
DOSSIERS AND SETTING UP PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TREASON,
BUT IT'S A SURE AN ACT AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S A CONSPIRACY AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES OF THE CRIME.
IT'S A VERY, VERY SERIOUS CRIME
AND PEOPLE SHOULD GO TO JAIL FOR
A LONG TIME.
>> Laura: ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN JAW BONING FOR 2 YEARS
ABOUT RUSSIA AND OTHER COUNTRIES
WANT TO METTLE IN OUR ELECTION,
THAT'S A CONCERN, BUT THERE
SHOULD BE ANOTHER CONCERN THAT
INDIVIDUALS IN THE UNITED STATES
WERE TRYING TO AFFECT THE
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
REMOVING HIM FROM OFFICE WITH
THIS SLOW ROLLING COUP GOING ON.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO CARRY ABOUT
MEDDLING WITH THE RUSSIANS BUT
DON'T CARE ABOUT IT WHEN DONE BY
THE DEEP STATE.
>> MEDDLING BY THE UKRAINE.
A COURT IN THE UKRAINE FOUND
A SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL DELIVERED
DIRT ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE HILLARY
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THERE WAS NO FINDING OF ANYTHING
RUSSIAN WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE ALREADY HAVE DEFINITIVE PROOF
THAT THE DEMOCRATS, HILLARY'S
PEOPLE AND THE DNC WERE USING
UKRANIAN OFFICIALS TO DIG UP
DIRT ON THE TRUISMS INCLUDING
THE POSSIBILITY THAT THE DIRT
WAS KNOWINGLY FALSIFIED
FAS KNOWINGLY FALSIFIED
FALSKNOWINGLY FALSIFIED
FALSIFOWINGLY FALSIFIED
FALSIFIEINGLY FALSIFIED
FALSIFIED.GLY FALSIFIED
AND THEY SAID JOE BIDEN CAVING
INTO CHINA.
THE KID GOT A 1.5-BILLION
DOLLARS DEPOSIT 8 DAYS LATER IN
HIS USELESS PRIVATE EQUITY FIRM.
$5 MILLION AFTER HE GETS TOSSED
OUT OF THE MILITARY.
>> Laura: YOU WERE GOING OVER
THERE.
>> I DIDN'T GO OVER THERE
BECAUSE THEY SURROUNDED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE WITH
DEMOCRATS AND PEOPLE TRYING TO
SET US UP.
I WAS GOING OVER THERE TO MAKE
SURE THEY INVESTIGATE THE
UKRANIAN COLLUSION WITH HILLARY
CLINTON'S PEOPLE.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO GO?
>> I WILL GO WHEN I AM SURE THEY
WON'T MISSTATE WHY I AM GOING
THERE.
THE BIDEN THING FELL INTO MY
LAP.
>> Laura: WE COVERED IT.
>> I KNOW.
YOU AND THE "WASHINGTON POST."
A LITTLE IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
CNN WOULD GO INTO A SEIZURE IF
THEY HAD TO COVER THAT.
MAYBE THE KID HAS TO GET $2
MILLION.
>> Laura: WE DON'T HAVE MANY
REPORTERS LEFT.
THEY USED TO INVESTIGATE ALL
CORRUPTION.
THEY WERE INTERESTED IN GETTING
TO THE BOTTOM OF ALL CORRUPTION.
NOW INTERESTED IN GETTING TRUMP.
>> TRUE OR NOT TRUE.
IF YOU PROVE IT, IT'S A GREAT
STORY.
>> Laura: I HAVE TO GET TO
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> I WILL PRESUME THEM PRESIDENT
THAT THEY DIDN'T DO FOR MY
PRESIDENT.
THEY WILL STILL NOT DOING IT.
ACCORDING TO MUELLER HE HAS TO
PROVE HIS INNOCENCE.
ABSURD.
>> Laura: I GUESS I HAVE TO GO
BACK TO LAW SCHOOL TO LEARN THE
NEW WAY OF PROVING YOU ARE
INNOCENT.
BARR'S STATUS YOU WANT.
WE WONDERED WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT AND WITH THE OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS.
JOHN HUBER IS DOING OUT IN
COLORADO.
WE WANT TO HEAR FROM HIM ON WHAT
HE SAID THERE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HUBER HUBER WAS ASKED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE FISA
APPLICATIONS AND HE PUT THAT ON
HOLD.
HE HASN'T BEEN ACTIVE IN RECENT
MONTHS.
SO DURHAM IS TAKING OVER THAT
ROLE.
THE OTHER ISSUES HE'S BEEN
WORKING ON RELATED TO HILLARY
CLINTON.
THOSE ARE WINDING DOWN AND
HOPEFULLY WE WILL NUMBER
A POSITION TO BRING THOSE TO
FRUITION.
>> Laura: WOW.
>> I APPRECIATE THE HONESTY AND
THE DELIVERY OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHOM I HAVE INCREASING
RESPECT FOR.
I GOT TO TELL YOU AS A FORMERUS
ATTORNEY AND ASSOCIATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO RAN THE CRIMINAL
SIDE OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT I
WOULD NOT STAND DOWN FOR
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATION OVER A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION IN A MILLION
YEARS.
NO WAY HUBER SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN
OUT OF THE WAY FOR THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL?
>> Laura: THAT WAS DONE BEFORE
BARR?
>> HE WAS BEING DIP LOHATTIC.
-- DIPLOMATIC.
I WATCHED HIS FACE AND HE SAID
THAT WITH A CERTAIN SORT OF
SARCASM.
I AM SURE HE WON'T ADMIT IT.
NO WAY SHOULD YOU STAND DOWN.
WHAT IS INVOLVED.
PERJURY TO THE FISA COURT.
A NATIONAL SECURITY COURT.
I HELPED TO ESTABLISH THE FISA
COURT WITH A FRIEND OF YOURS.
JOE.
HE WAS THE FIRST LAWYER AND I
HELPED WRITE IT WHEN I WORKED
FOR PRESIDENT FORD AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL LEVY.
WHAT THEY DID TO THE FISA COURT,
IT'S SUCH AN INTRUSION INTO OUR
PRIVACY.
IT'S LIKE DOING AN OPERATION OF
OUR BRAIN.
THE GOVERNMENT DOING AN PRIGS OF